and uh yeah the problem is the white  king is completely stuck  you can give up the white Rook go with  some pawns should we show the Checkmate  on the board on the board I think we  might see a resignation any moment but  okay he's going to try and make a new  Queen Magnus is going to take this rook  and he's going to trap the white King by  bringing his Rook across white can make  a new Queen but too slow the king is  trapped and uh we'll see okay similar to  this at least happen on the board right  now  uh this King  nowhere to go and we see Magnus play  that move in the current position he is  threatening the killer blue pushing the  pawn forward checkmate  and there we go I have a result the  quarterfinal match is over Magnus  Carlsen wins it in three games Arjun  aragaisy he looks devastated but he put  up a good fight he almost won the first  game but Magnus fought back to draw that  game and winning two games in a row  Magnus Carlsen is ready for the same